Speaker 1: Sometimes we jokingly use the term
brain worms.
And what we mean sometimes by brain worms
is somebody's abilities to think critically
and consistently.
Are either suspended deliberately or just
not functioning.
We finally got a very interesting interview.
Fox interviewed a supporter of Georgia Republican
Senate candidate Herschel Walker, and they
actually asked her, what about the fact that
he paid for an abortion for a woman?
He urged to get the abortion after he impregnated
her.
What about that?
Because this woman is presumably pro-life,
anti-choice, anti-abortion, and he claims
to be as well.
And she says, we've all done things when we
were young.
Herschel Walker was a nearly 50 year old man
when this happened.
When we were young, he's 60 now.
He was almost 50 when he did this.
What the hell are you talking about?
And this is an example of the total cognitive
dissonance that exists and the inability to
reach certain people, which is where I'm going
to focus in here.
But let's take a look at this clip.
Okay.
Speaker 4: The matter to you if it's true
or not and even if.
As long as he is had a change of heart.
I mean, we all do things when we're young
and naive.
He's an adult now.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
He was an adult of nearly 50 years of age.
When he impregnated a woman.
Urged her to get an abortion paid for the
abortion.
And now in this second case that we now know
of, implicitly and menacingly threatened the
woman he impregnated by saying you would not
be safe if you did not get an abortion and
the eventual child would not be safe if you
didn't get an abortion.
So there's a bunch of different stories here.
Let's talk about them.
First is the realization that many of us have
had.
You really can't reason with these voters,
right?
What if that woman who we just saw the interview
with, she straight up says he's changed his
mind and he did this when he was young.
We all do things when we were young, he was
almost 50.
Okay.
You can't reason with her.
So what do you have to do?
You have to take the money that you might
spend trying to reach those people.
And instead you have to target rational people.
To just get them out to vote.
So as a political strategy, we've said before,
where do you spend limited resources?
How do you invest the resources and time that
you have?
Is it on trying to change the minds of people
like that woman?
Seems quite fruitless, I think you would agree,
at least from an election story interpersonally.
Sure.
Try to talk sense into her.
But as far as we have x number of dollars
to spend, do we try to just get out the vote
from people who already lean in our direction?
Or do we try to change the minds of people
like that?
You've got to just try to get people to vote
that are already that are not totally bamboozled
and disconnected from reality like that woman.
That's number one.
Number two, this idea of redemption.
This is an extraordinary get out of jail free
card for the right, which is important for
us to understand.
Redemption can be used to explain away any
transgression no matter what.
As long as the individual has completely,
implausibly repented or said why, they've
changed their mind.
And it's used by the right to never have to
actually consider voting for a Democrat.
To never consider that the Democrat may actually
be the better choice, as Raphael Warnock is
in the state of Georgia.
We saw this with Trump, Donald Trump, 68 years
of life, pro-choice.
All of a sudden, he's running to be the Republican
presidential nominee and he needs some way
to no longer be pro-choice that people will
believe.
Trump comes up with the completely unbelievable
story.
Well, you know, I was very pro-choice my whole
life.
This is Trump story, okay?
I was I used to be pro-choice, but I met a
woman who had a kid and I met the kid and
it was a great kid.
And the woman said, you know, at one point,
I wasn't sure if it was the right thing to
have this pregnancy to carry this pregnancy
to term.
I thought about getting an abortion and I
didn't.
And Trump goes, You know what?
My 68 years of being pro-choice, I flushed
him down the toilet 10 to 15 times because
I met a kid I liked.
That's the story.
I don't believe that that's an absurd story.
I know many of you don't believe that story,
but it's a get out of jail free card for the
right wingers who go.
He saw the light eventually.
Yes, it took him 68 years, but he eventually
saw the light.
On religion, we know Trump is not religious.
We know Trump has no idea about religion.
He didn't grow up religious or any of it,
but he started saying, I love the Bible.
Oh, really, Mr. President.
At the time, he wasn't President.
Mr. Trump.
Sir, what's your favorite passage?
Oh, that's personal.
I don't want to get into that.
Do you believe that?
Do you believe that Trump is a Bible guy?
Are you a First Amendment?
First Amendment?
Are you a New Testament or an Old Testament
guy?
Oh, both.
Oh, okay.
Completely unbelievable.
But the evangelical right eventually came
around and said, well, he came he eventually
figured out the right position on abortion
and he's religious now and he loves the Bible
and blah, blah, blah.
So the redemption story is a blank slate.
Get out of jail free card if they want it.
If they want to if they want to bury you,
then they don't use the redemption story.
But as long as you've said I changed my mind,
they completely uncritically accept it if
it's convenient.
Now, let's kind of go to the last thing.
Speaking very narrowly.
And specifically, how do people like this
have a driver's license?
How do people like this hold a job?
Like the woman who we saw there, she's holding
a kid in the interview.
How does she parent a child?
Some of these folks, I genuinely don't know
how they get through the day.
I don't know how they accomplish the simplest
tasks grocery shopping, figuring out the right
amount of Tylenol to take.
Quite frankly, I don't know how they survive.
I don't.
Because they are so.
I don't even want to characterize it with
adjectives.
It's disturbing to think about the number
of folks that are this clueless.
That just live in the country with us.
And it helps us understand how Trump won and
unfortunately, why Herschel Walker may also
win on Tuesday.
If our Georgia friends and neighbors don't
get
out
to vote.